let's rejoin the conversation for part
two of my interview with dr joseph urban
i sort of imagine again as a
non-mathematician that mathematicians
are
you know sitting in their offices with
pencil and paper and writing out obscure
theorems but
you know like everything else it seems
uh if we can get machines to help and so
would it transforms the scale just in
the same way that an engineer working
with a tall building
you know isn't using his slide rule and
pen and paper to work out the stress
at every joint in a steel frame of a
skyscraper that's
you know 2 000 feet tall right there
they're
they're running some program that that
in a batch mode
you know examines all of those stresses
together and
i would think that the same thing would
apply to mathematics and i guess now
now it actually does that you're working
on such hard problems that
that this could really change the the
process of doing
uh theoretical or even applied
mathematics
yeah so in indeed like this this was
really
something which people seriously doubted
that
tom tom would achieve like they probably
even first doubted that they would get
the
sort of proof that was like
computationally
supported and then they very much
doubted
that he will get it formally formally
verified
and all of that happened and i would say
what was also quite interesting so i
i mostly very quickly smith's art
project that i might have mentioned or
we will talk about
but sometime in 2011
i met thomas and i told him
well you have a big project which is
almost finished
and i have my technology which learns
from the proof
so why don't we try it on your
big project and what happened about one
one year after that
was that with cesari kalishik we got
something like 40 percent of the lemmas
there were about 20 000 at the time in
in that project we could prove
automatically by
using some kinds of machine learning and
combination with
uh systems like e-priver vampires e3 et
cetera
so so that that would be like my
add-on on like what where
tom put it right like tom tom has very
hard
in the sort of interactive theorem
proving like the form of true
verification
and what me and cesari and other people
especially now
on on this big project have been doing
is to really
try to automate as much of that work as
possible
yeah and and maybe another thing to
clarify
is this is a really very uh exciting
kind of marriage of technologies i mean
their improvers have been around for a
long time and they've ins in
theory you might say been capable of
doing these large mathematical proofs
but they haven't been fast enough
and so the key thing has been improving
their strategies so
uh just to really simplify it down uh
your your approver could
say pick the smallest next rule that
would transform
some element of your current
mathematical proof but that might not be
the right one to pick there might be
other metrics as opposed to just picking
the smallest one
it seems like people have have started
to almost exhaust
those strategies i mean the major
approvers get better every year
but you've managed with machine learning
really learning the strategies
of taking these simple small steps in
automated theorem proving and and
figured out
how to pick the best strategy that gets
you to the answer fast enough
but still using the the mechanisms of
automated theorem proving of
mathematical logic
rather than statistics yeah so
so we you know we we do several things
like
this has been a large project so what
you what you are describing
is what we call basically
learning of crm improving strategies
so you have somebody like stefan schultz
who creates an
excellent open source automated theorem
theory
and he he even is
is great enough to to define a
domain-specific language
in which you can invent new new
strategies
and you know like stefan actually for
for his phd series he
he was doing machine learning right like
he's like the
great grandfather of what we are doing
what we are doing today
uh it is just that he sort of got to
too much um i i would say
sight tracked by by the beauty of
implementing eprover
rather than by the ugliness of
implementing
machine learning but
for example you can really readily take
uh
the interface like the domain specific
language for
constructing various search strategies
that stefan has in improvement
and and do some sort of evolutionary or
iterated local search algorithms for
finding optimal or good strategies for
sets of programs so so that's definitely
very rewarding thing where some
various kinds of machine learning work
for you
but what we did i would say even more
in in the sort of recent project is that
we we sort of replace this
um invention of
the pre-specified blocks um
and written in the domain-specific
language
by a big blob which is
something some black box statistical
machine learner like for example some
neural network or
some decision trees or
just some logistic regression
and uh it it turns out
that plugging in
a well-trained big blob
like this with today's machine learners
can can do really
a lot of things for you so we we have
experiments where my student
zargartso took the best strategies that
we have developed in the
sort of older evolutionaries i think
and he trained on their proves this
sort of decision trees basically this
big blob
the statistical machine learning and
even though
the epriver that he was using was
totally stupid like it wasn't using any
advanced strategy trim ordering literal
selection
it it learned so well that it was
beating
the the three the best
invented predefined uh strategies
so it's it's really good fun how all
these things
interact now it's really quite exciting
yeah fantastic so
uh one of the questions that i often
have about uh
machine learning solutions is you know
they can find great solutions in
particular spaces but then
what's the transferability when you go
out of that space so you found that
say if you develop a strategy for all
sorts of theorems about
number theory does it then if you go
over to group theory or some other
area of mathematics do those strategies
also work
for proving ethereums with those uh
axiomatizations
very good question adam excellent
question uh
so so different methods work differently
when when i did the first strategy
invention system
my initial intuition was that it will be
and i actually programmed it to play
that it will be
proving different specialist strategies
like my
guiding idea well what was this
evolution
where you have the giraffe that
specializes on eating
the leaves from the high trees and then
you have the bat
and like all these different
creatures each of them taking its niche
but but what happened to me is that the
evolutionary mechanism
developed a super strong generalist
strategy
that was uh that was much better than
what whatever
uh the best uh pre-coded strategy
uh could do so that's a really really
like the evolution of humans you know
became the ultimate generalist and and
uh took over the world for better or
worse and
uh you found the same thing with your
algorithms yeah
so so this was really quite quite
interesting and
it's probably because for example on on
the mesa problems
you even though that the problems come
from a large mathematical library with
many different problems so you could say
that this is really pretty universal
they are still encoded in a particular
way so for example
the the type encoding in misai
leads to quite long clauses with many
assumptions uh with many like negative
literals
so what i can imagine is that this
particular encoding even though you are
talking
about very general corpus
has still some particularities
that are well handled by by some
particular kind kind of strategy so so
that could be
that could be one one effect there uh
about the sort of statistical machine
learners that's also
fairly interesting so so we have some
which are
really symbolized so so they are looking
like
is this now group theory is this
topology is this number theory
well whatever and those
definitely will not generalize uh
to to other domains but then
what we did later is for example
where we use just
like an abstract tree of the formula
where we about each symbol only know its
arity
and to which other symbols which are
again just characterized by
its arity they are linked and we
characterize the
abstract syntax trees by by a set of
walks of length three or four for
example
and already this like very sort of
anonymous abstract
description gets us very similar
performance as the one where we are
using symbols so so that's quite
surprising
and another sort of bit of information
is that we also do it with a special
neural network which also
totally disregards the names of the
symbols
it only considers the graph
how how they are sort of how are the
symbols linked together
and again this graph neural network that
we now have
it's probably the best thing that that
we have
in for machine learning guidance so
you and we have actually done
experiments when
we have seen we have tested like we have
as the neural network
what do you think is the name of the
symbol
and quite often we can see some
interesting sort of transfer so so for
example
you have quite a lot of theorems like a
duality between
intersection and union like some
demorgan laws basically in boolean
algebras
so quite often it would guess that this
symbol
is union even though it's intersection
and the symbol is intersection even
though it's union
or you have some theorem about real
numbers like real calculus
and it would guess that it's complex
numbers and complex calculus
so so these methods do transfer
to to some extent yeah although it's
interesting that it sounds like one of
the things that you've done
is to uh create some of the abstraction
input abstraction of the input yourself
right by removing
some of the symbols and just focusing on
the structure
um you've pulled the machine here are
the essential features
of the domain or where there's this very
broad domain to focus on
that that prevents it from getting
itself into trouble
yeah yeah that's definitely the case
when we when we did this
abstraction by itself by by ourselves
then
when we do it via the graph neural
network
it's sort of no feature engineering
that's the sort of buzzword
that the deep learning community really
likes no feature
no feature engineering and uh
well you could stay you could still sort
of say that we are engineering
the surf architecture of the neural
network etc
but there you are sort of even
this part you are sort of leaving up
to to the back propagation to to the
training of the neural network basically
wow fascinating so i want to maybe shift
gears a little bit because kind of one
of the enablers of
this whole proc this whole study that
you've done is
having a lot of the mathematics already
formalized right so you can't prove a
big theorem
on anything unless you have lots of
background information for the machine
to do some search over to try to
turn it into a solution for the question
you've asked
so all a lot of this work i guess is all
based on work you've been doing a very
long time on the mizar library of
formalized mathematics all
formalized in languages that the theorem
provers can consume can you
talk about misar and how that fed into
the ai for reason project
oh yeah that's a nice question
so um
is one system in a bigger category
of interactive theorem previous or proof
assistance
and it's really an old project it's one
of the oldest it started in 1973
in poland um
by a guy called andre tribulettes who
was a
very good mathematician he did a phd in
topology
and he had trouble with
various refactorings of his phd thesis
as he was adding new theorems and new
stuff to his phd thesis
he basically wanted to have some system
that would assist him like once he had
made some proof and now he changed
slightly a definition or whatever
he wouldn't like the proof to go wrong
like like to to basically have some
assistant or bookkeeper for him helping
him with that
and he he was also very interested in
linguistics
so he started to basically analyze
the structure of mathematical articles
and according to that he and his
colleagues
started to create a language that would
sort of resemble that would be formal
like a programming language
but it would still resemble how
mathematicians are
writing the the formulas and
the truths so so they
they sort of proceeded in some sort of
splendid isolation behind the iron
curtain
without being known too much by by the
sort of
western uh crm proving community which
was sort of
more into like computer science stuff
rather than
into formalization of mathematics and
in 1989 they decided
to that the system and the language is
developed well enough that they will
start
really like a broad scale formalization
of mathematics to
to sort of test the system
as you go like here motor was
experienced not only doctrine so you
need to
you really need to go into more advanced
things
to be able to develop the system further
and to see
like what are still the problems of the
system and the language etc
and they they they got funded
by like after the revolution also they
got for example
office of naval research uh funding
and uh they uh
developed quite early quite a lot of
mathematics in the system so by
i would say by the year 2000
they might have i don't know like 700
missouri articles in all sorts of
uh mathematical areas they they even
like this office of naylaris and
grant asked them to formalize a
reasonably advanced book by danascott
and his colleagues about continuous
lattices
i think by like 2000 to 2003 they they
formalized like 60 percent of the
reasonable advanced book so
it's it's it's quite a lot of
mathematics
and the beauty of it for me was
that not only it was mathematical which
i was sort of interested in
but but also it was using quite common
foundations like basically first auto
logic and
set theory so i could quite easily
translate it to automated theorem
previously
and vampire etc and experiment with that
and yeah
um yeah and undo the sort of machine
learning stuff on
on on top of that so uh
it's it's a project i sort of got
involved i even did some formalizations
in it to see how
how how the formalization works
well this is fascinating i actually had
no idea about this history i should have
i should have read up before but
uh to to think about this formalization
uh
occurring you know starting back in the
70s so
long before any of the the modern
theorem provers that i'm
i'm familiar with like he even got
started um
mathematicians were doing this
groundwork anticipating
uh that all of this stuff would be uh
you know very useful
uh and you've been able to to leapfrog
off of this big library and i guess
transform it too right because it wasn't
written in a
modern knowledge representation language
you had to translate this
into tptp or or other languages that the
theorem provers actually used today
yeah yeah so that was like a big part of
my phd thesis i i really
sort of wanted to see how much of the
manually so well like it's it's never
completely manual when you when you are
proving things in in these interactive
previews like you have some
small efficient automation in in there
but but i basically wanted to see how
how much
of the theorems which at the time could
have been like i know 30
40 000 theorems
the the automated theorem like e and
vampire
can can prove so so indeed like
i needed to to translate it which for
for me
wasn't so difficult like i said it's
basically first of all logic
and then i the automated theorem
previous and
uh it gave me some numbers like gave me
like something like 40 percent if i
could
like use the premises
that they're manual is selected by the
author
of the of the mesa proof and that that
was really quite surprising
like because for example the music
people really
didn't believe in automated fear
improvement
so they were very skeptical that the
automated theorem previously will be
able to prove anything
useful and the 40 percent number really
surprised them as much as it surprised
me well
that's always satisfying where you can
come up with a kind of unintuitive
result where there's a community
that doesn't think something would be
successful and darn it you show that it
actually does
oh yeah yeah we'll pause the
conversation there
and return for part three of my
interview with dr joseph urban